hello everyone welcome back to the
channel today we've got yet another
systems design video for you now before
we go ahead and get started let's play a
quick game which is am I a intoxicated
or B tired unfortunately because it's a
Wednesday the answer is going to be
tired which is why I want to get through
this one kind of fast so let's go ahead
and get started all right so let's go
ahead and get into it so unless you're
watching the super secret Jordan has no
life only fans version of the systems
design videos you're probably watching
this on YouTube which means you at least
understand the product that I'm going to
attempt to be building Here YouTube and
Netflix is just going to be a video
watching site where a given Channel or a
user can post a variety of videos they
can watch a variety of videos and such
an example would be one right here where
the video has a title a number of views
can have some comments it's able to
buffer in real time as your network
bandwidth fluctuates and so the gist is
that we're going to attempt to build
something like this that actually scales
to billions of users so let's go ahead
and outline some problem requirements so
the first is the users can post videos
the second is that users can watch
videos the reason I have the arrow here
is because we're going to be watching a
lot of videos as one does users can also
comment on videos and users can also
search for videos by name the reason I'm
not really doing views as much in this
one is frankly because if you watch the
tiny URL video the process that we would
use to be aggregating video views is
very similar that we would be using to
aggregate uh tiny URL uh link clicks
that we use in that video so I think it
would be redundant I would just
recommend you go watch that video as
well if you're curious on view
aggregation so again number two is going
to be the most important number two
being that we can watch videos so we
want to optimize for our read speeds so
let's go ahead and quickly outline some
capacity estimates while we're at it cuz
I said we're going to be building for
large scale let's imagine our product
has a billion users I wish I would be
retired right now in addition our
average video is going to have around
1,000 views that being said some are
going to be super popular right certain
channels such as myself of course with
billions of subscribers have millions of
views per video additionally we've also
got videos being around 100 megabytes on
average there are about a million of
them posted a day and if we were to go
ahead and figure out how much storage
that needs to basically hold all of
these videos we can take that 100
megabyte size per video multiply it by
the 1 million videos that are getting
posted per day we can also multiply that
by the approximate number of days per
year I use 400 instead of 365 and that
comes to about 40 pedabytes of storage
per year now obviously this is going to
be a ton that being said when you're
making a crap ton of money that's doable
you just get a lot of hard drives so
before we actually go ahead and get into
any you know design or server choices or
database schemas or anything like that
that let's go ahead and do an
introduction to video streaming so the
first big concept that we have to think
about is that we are going to support
streaming or rather watching footage on
many different types of devices right I
might be able to watch on my phone you
on your laptop someone else on their
tablet and basically the gist is that we
may have to support many different types
of them additionally we have to be able
to support different networking speeds
right me on my gigaby e ethernet is
going to be able to watch Clips at a
higher rate than you can on your 2G cell
phone so as a result of that what would
be really really great is if uh certain
devices with different bandwidths or
different abilities to load footage can
actually load them dynamically right so
for example a slow phone might first be
watching some footage in 480p switch
over to 720 maybe they get slower again
go back to 480 a medium device might be
fluctuating between 4K 1080p 720 and
then back and forth and then a super
fast connection might just be able to
watch the entire video in 4k which would
be great so so the gist is that in order
to do that we need to basically be able
to support multiple different
resolutions for our clips and also to
support different devices multiple
different
encodings okay so let's talk now about
video chunking which is going to allow
us to do this in a more efficient manner
so keep in mind that we want multiple
different resolutions for every single
clip we want multiple different
encodings and what that really means is
that when we upload a clip from our
device let's say I'm posting a Jordan
has no video YouTube is going to take my
video and make multiple different copies
of it right we would need a 1080p
version we would need a 720p version and
if you're a device and you want to
constantly be switching between uh those
two as your kind of bandwidth is scaling
up and down or your network speeds are
scaling up and down we would want to
load both of those clips and the problem
with that is that we don't need both of
those clips right we only need the parts
that don't overlap with one another if
I've already watched you know the first
quarter of the clip in 1080p then I only
want to load the remaining 3/4s in 720p
and so the way that we can do this is
actually by splitting all of our videos
into chunks so for example if I've got
my 1080P and my 720p video right here
maybe I can watch the first two chunks
in 1080P my device then realizes its
Network speeds have gotten worse so it's
going to say hey let's load the 720p
chunk after that oh wait it got better
let's go back to 1080 oh no worse again
and do 720 for the last two so the fact
that we actually have all of these
different chunks means that with a
relatively small granularity we can pick
the right chunk at the right time so
that we can take advantage of our
changing networking
speeds so let's quickly outline the
different advantages of splitting our
videos into a bunch of different chunks
the first is going to be parallel
uploads so imagine that this were our
server or our backend or S3 or anything
like that basically wherever the chunks
are going to end up if we can do this in
parallel we can effectively just
establish multiple different ports for
this guy to uh be connected to and as a
result of that we can just send the
chunks on different ports not really a
huge deal frankly I'm not even sure this
would increase speeds very much because
your bandwidth might be limited from
your device but no big deal the bigger
thing on the other hand is there is a
lower barrier to starting a video so
rather than having to load this entire
huge file and get it on your device what
you can actually do is load just the
first chunk of it once the first chunk
is loaded we can start watching and then
from there we can start loading the
second chunk the third chunk and the
fourth chunk and so when you think of it
that's why on YouTube you know you can
get partway through a video and then it
might start buffering we're only loading
a little bit at a time and then
asynchronously in the background loading
the rest of it okay and then of course
the last thing we just covered on the
previous slide which is that as our
networking speeds change we can grab the
best chunk for us so we're going to do
so based on our current networking
abilities and as a result we now have a
bunch of different chunks per video
we're going to need some some sort of
table or some sort of database to keep
track of all of these chunks because
things are going to get complicated when
we have so many different copies of
every single
file okay so let's start outlining some
of the database tables that we'll
actually be able to use for our service
I'm not going to go into these in too
much detail I'm going to outline a
schema and then possibly suggest an
actual database Choice here but I think
it's worth noting that because a lot of
these are not going to be the B uh the
main bottleneck in our system we don't
have to over really optimize on them too
much just choose a decent schema and be
reasonable about that so first let's
start with a subscribers table so
imagine that we have a user ID and
another user ID that describes who we're
subscribed to this is going to allow us
to say you know if I'm Jordan and I'm a
viewer of YouTube videos who am I
actually subscribed to that's going to
be a query I have to run pretty
frequently when establishing something
like you know the equivalent of my news
feed in YouTube and again I'm not going
to describe how we would actually build
something like that out because we've
basically already made a video on that
right it's the same problem as like the
Twitter Facebook Instagram Reddit
problem and it's the same exact thing
where you know when a video gets
published you would actually deliver it
to all of these caches based on who
you're subscribed to so again not going
to cover that too much uh just watch the
Twitter video if you're more concerned
on how to build something like a home
screen or a Newsfeed but we do still
need this subscribers table for a
different reason which I'll cover later
in the video so the nice thing about
that is because we want to know you know
I'm Jordan who am I subscribed to we
should probably index on the user ID
field so I can quickly find all the
people I'm subscribed to and we should
also partition on that user ID field so
that all of the queries to figure out
who am I subscribed to go to the same
physical Noe additionally if we really
wanted to another thing that we should
know is if I have a YouTube channel as I
do who subscribed to me well the nice
thing about this is that so we don't
have to make a kind of you know two-part
write every single time someone
subscribes to someone we can use change
data capture instead to ensure that
eventually our second table will be
updated right and we can do this using
Kafka as we've done so many times uh in
the remainder of these videos and Flink
so if we have all these subscribers
right here we can actually partition
Kafka on this subscribe two field and
then that way you know if user 10 has a
YouTube channel you can see that they
have subscribers three six and five
those all get added and cached locally
in our Flink node and we can either make
a second database table out of that or
we can just cash it which personally I
would like to do for later purposes in
the video and I'll explain that down the
line so this is going to come in handy
when uploading videos we'll talk about
that in a bit the second third and
fourth tables that I wanted to talk
about I will now get started on the
first is going to be user videos so this
is just outlining if I'm a user what
videos have I actually posted that's
going to have a user ID it's going to
have a video ID it's going to have the
timestamp that we actually posted that
video and then of course some metadata
about the video like the name and the
description so of course for a given
user we want to be able to quickly
figure out all of the videos that
they've posted and we should do so by
keeping all of those entries on one
single note we can do that by
partitioning on the user ID and then
using some combination of the user ID
the video ID and the timestamp as either
a sort key or an index so that I can
basically quickly figure out all the
videos that I've posted in order by the
time that I posted them so that should
hopefully be self-explanatory again most
of these tables I'm not really too
concerned with performance- wise because
we're more concerned with actually
watching the videos not really loading
the metadata for them okay next we've
got a users table don't worry about this
one too much let's keep it simple we've
got a user ID an email a password
whatever other information you have to
store and of course if we partition on
our user ID field and index on our user
ID field it should be relatively easy to
figure out where a row for a given user
actually lives and not have to do some
sort of distributed query the last
aspect of at least this slide here is
going to be the video video comments
table so for this one we've actually got
a video ID and I should preface this
with saying that in reality it would
probably be like a channel ID and a
video ID because eventually that's how
I'm planning on uniquely identifying a
video is a combination of just some
channel name and then also the video ID
that comes with it and so we can
partition on that so that all the
comments for a single video go on the
same node and then we can also use the
time stamp as part of the index so that
they're sorted by timestamp and of
course have the actual comment poster ID
the content etc etc etc so another thing
that is worth talking about is actually
going to be our video chunks table where
as you can see we now have a bunch of
encodings and resolutions to worry about
now I've pretty stupidly actually switch
the order of these so h264 would be the
encoding 1080p would be the resolution
but the gist is that by partitioning by
video ID we ensure that all the chunks
for a given video should be on the same
note note additionally by sorting by the
video ID encoding resolution and then
after that the chunk order we can
basically say Hey you know if I have
really good interview uh internet and I
can watch every single clip at 1080p on
the h264 format what I can go ahead and
do is just load all of them they'll be
right next to one another on disk and
that should be a simple query so again
that's going to allow easily getting all
the chunks for a given resolution even
if we can't load all of the chunks for a
given resolution because our Network
speeds are fluctuating it's still a
pretty easy query to go and get the ones
from the other resolution I wouldn't
really worry about it all too much and
then of course we would have some sort
of hash to describe the chunk and then
possibly the the URL to wherever we're
storing it whether that's S3 or Hadoop
or something else so let's actually talk
about some database choices that we want
to use for the aention tables so the
main thing to note is that we're going
to be worrying about reads a lot more
than we're worrying about wrs and
typically when we're worrying about
reads what we basically want to do is
keep our database schema simple and you
know cache where possible and you know
we can get away with using something
like my SQL here because it actually
uses a b tree so if you recall uh the B
tree is just a big tree on
disk and it is a lot easier to iterate
this on disk tree than it is to check
multiple different SS tables which would
be the case for an LSM tree index and so
something like a b tree index would be
perfectly acceptable here and uh as a
result of that I tend to opt for or
something like my SQL for all of those
tables that I listed the one caveat
being that some videos may actually get
a lot of comments right because at the
end of the day if it's a super popular
video the first 10 minutes you may get a
ton of comments and my SQL might not be
able to handle that type of writing load
so for that type of situation I think
you could make the argument to actually
use Cassandra here for a couple of
reasons one the LSM tree architecture
means that all rights first go to
memory the second thing is that it's a
leaderless architecture right so as long
as we part Partition by that combination
of like Channel
ID and video
ID we can Partition by that and then the
time stamp is actually going to make it
such that you know no two comments are
exactly the same and we're not really
going to have to deal with any right
conflicts uh unless of course we support
comment editing or we support child
conflicts because then we can have
dependency issues where let's imagine I
wrote a comment to this replica and then
I try and edit it but that goes to this
replica before the comment itself
already exists then Cassandra might be
problematic and we might have to look
for a different solution but assuming we
just allow writing com uh comments we
don't allow editing them and we don't
allow replies to comments then we
shouldn't have to worry about using
Cassandra it should be
okay okay The Next Step that we're going
to start to actually talk about is video
uploads now these are going to
potentially get a little bit complicated
but the main idea to remember here is
that we aren't uploading to our database
very very often again I upload once per
week for example and I watch many many
more YouTube videos than that so if
we're uploading very infrequently the
idea is to do as much work as possible
on the right path and as little work as
possible on the read path because most
of us are just watching videos the
majority of the time and the main idea
here is we want to keep these relatively
cheap and when I say cheap I mean
literally cost wise let's keep them
cheap and also correct if I'm uploading
a video I expect to see it eventually
doesn't have to be instant but it's got
to be up there eventually
so the idea is for each chunk we've got
to do some sort of post-processing on it
right because we want to store multiple
variants we might have to store a 480p
version a 720p version a 1080p version
and all of those things are going to
require us to store multiple copies as
well as the different encodings so again
we can basically maintain a list of
servers that are going to do this
processing for us and it doesn't really
matter which actually does the
processing as long as it eventually gets
done so with that being said what can we
actually do well for starters we know
that processing these events takes time
actually converting a video from one
format to the other it is relatively
compute heavy same goes for encoding it
to a variety of different formats and so
we're not just going to like upload a
video to a server and be like hey do
this synchronously and then get back to
me whether or not it worked we're going
to have to do this in the background of
our application and typically when that
happens we're going to need some sort of
message broker so assuming that we put
events on a broker and process them in
the background around what type of
broker should we actually use well let's
start to think of it remember I said
already that we don't actually really
care which one of this guy this guy or
this guy does our processing for a given
chunk so what type of broker should we
actually use well in this case I think
what we would want is probably going to
be an inmemory message CU so if you
recall at least from our Concepts videos
the the reason behind using something
like a Kafka broker or a log based
message broker is that there's only one
consumer and because there's only one
consumer and because all messages are
replayable we can actually build up some
State on our consumer the issue with
something like an inmemory broker is
that you don't really know that the
order uh of the messages is going to be
consistent especially if they get
replayed and in addition to that uh you
know it might not be as durable you can
use things like a write ahead log and
replication of your broker to ensure
that every event gets played once but if
the gist is you want to be able to
maintain the same exact state if your
broker were to go down then it is going
to be the case that you would much
rather use Kafka that being said we
don't actually really care about State
because all our consumer is going to do
is read
file process
file and then rate
file and so when you're just reading a
file processing and writing it we don't
actually care what happens from message
to message everything that we need to
know about what we're doing is
encapsulated within one message and so
we don't have to maintain any state
additionally we want to get this process
done as fast as possible you know as
long as it's not going to make us
sacrifice uh read speed so as a result
of that using something like an
in-memory message CU can allow us to use
some sort of uh round robin load
balancing where basically as each of
these guys is ready to take an event
they can pull one off the queue put it
over here right so no one else is going
to get it and then when they're done
they can reach back out saying done and
then finally this event is going to get
deleted from the message broker and so
for that reason I definitely support
using an in-memory message broker for
this type of task uh something like
rabbit mq Amazon sqs any of those types
of solutions I think would work great
here active mq as
well okay so now let's go ahead and talk
about chunks so keep in mind that we now
have this message broker right here
we've got a bunch of processing nodes
that are reading from the message broker
and the question is what do we actually
put in the broker well the answer should
be certainly not the chunks the reason
being that the chunks are going to be
decently big you know they might not be
multiple gigabytes but they might be a
couple hundred megabytes and as a result
of that they are probably too big to
actually put in the broker and so
ideally what we would first want to do
is upload them to some sort of either
distributed file store or some object
store and then after doing so we can put
a reference to them in the broker right
so for example chunk goes here and then
we say like
chunk at some URL and that's going to be
going into our Rabbid mq now it is
possible that we can have partial
failure States here right where one is
going to go through and then two doesn't
go through uh the big thing to note
there is it doesn't really matter right
now we're storing a few extra chunks uh
but at the end of the day we can always
run some sort of background cleanup
job
where we go through S3 uh and we would
then basically say do we see this in our
chunk metadata table if not uh get rid
of it if we do then keep it so I think
that is preferable to having to do
something like a two-phase commit right
here which basically we want to avoid at
all costs unless we absolutely need it
so the question now is we know we're
putting our chunks somewhere where are
we actually putting them well I think
we've got a couple of options the first
is going to be hdfs or Hadoop
distributed file store so htfs would be
run on a cluster of nodes like so and
what we could actually do if we really
cared about our uh you know our
processing speeds is we could actually
run our uh you know our consumers or our
processing nodes that do the encoding on
hdfs right so you know we might devote
some resources to
processing and in addition some
resources to actual storage and that is
something that we can can do and so the
nice thing about that is we would get
really good data locality right because
all these guys are probably in the same
data center at least similar to one
another they're going to be able to
process and write these chunks back to
hdfs Super quickly compared to something
like S3 where you know you've got S3
over here on the right and every single
one of these nodes is going to have to
be making networking calls multiple
different times to load every single
Chunk from net uh S3 and then write it
back so hdfs is probably going to be the
optimal solution if we care about our
right speeds however it is worth noting
that in practice two big things come up
one hdfs is just like objectively more
expensive right so S3 is going to be
cheaper another thing is that truthfully
in modern Computing or at least from
what I understand about modern data
centers we're actually going to be a lot
more CPU bound than we are network bound
and so even all of these calls are going
to be expensive even though they're
going to be expensive what's more
important is the fact that this is just
going to take
time and when you look at the amount of
time relative to the networking speed
versus the CPU speed it's actually
probably going to be more significant on
the CPU end and we probably won't notice
as much latency as a result of basically
those networking calls and so
considering it's cheaper considering we
don't really care that much about making
these wrs or these uploads super fast I
actually am going to go with the S3
solution I imagine this is probably more
similar to what these companies are
doing in real
life okay so now this is where things
start getting kind of complex which is
that we are going to talk about
aggregation so we've got a bunch of
different processor nodes right
processor
processor blah blah
blah and they're going to be outputting
a bunch of different copies of every
single chunk and considering that these
are all distributed nodes how can we
actually figure out when a video has had
all of its chunks finished processes
so this is kind of the solution that I
came up with I think this would probably
be the most controversial part of the
video in terms of people trying to
correct me in the comments so please
feel free to go ahead if you want to but
ultimately this is the solution I'm
going to go with so the first thing is
that imagine we've got three chunks to
upload like I mentioned the first thing
that we're going to do is literally just
put them in object storage which is
going to be S3 right here once that has
completed it needs to actually finish we
can then go start in queuing the
metadata for all of those chunks in
rabbit mq so we would say like you know
chunk one is s3.com ABC chunk two is
s3.com
sdef and then in addition in parallel to
uploading these events we would also
upload a second event over here to a
different Kafka queue the reason I use
Kafka is because we want to maintain
this to keep State over here in Flink
which I'll explain what that does in a
second so the type of message that we
would send to this Kafka over
here is is this guy imagine we have
video 10 and we're uploading that I
would basically say in advance hey video
10 is three chunks that's what we're
going to be looking out for so then we
can have our Flink over here which is
going to be keeping State the reason I
use Flink as always is because it makes
sure that every message actually gets
processed at least once so even due to
failures or anything like that within
our system eventually it'll come back up
or another node will take its place and
the message will still get processed so
video 10 we've got three chunks it means
now that this guy knows that video 10
has three chunks coming in and it's
actually going to be able to wait on
them so I can say video 10 is three and
then imagine chunk C isn't in yet once I
see chunk a and once I see chunk B we're
still not done eventually chunk C gets
over here to flank and then we say okay
actually we're good to go how does chunk
C get there well all of the processors
once they're done completing their
actions are going to first do two things
one is that they're actually going to
let me switch up the order here
one is that they're going to upload that
chunk information to Kafka basically
saying hey we finished incing this the
second is that they're going to go back
to Rabbit mq and say hey get rid of my
chunk so I no longer need to process
this thing anymore it's completely done
I've alerted flank that this entire
process is complete and so now what's
going to happen is that it's going to
get dced from rabbit mq it's going to
get inced to Kafka over here and it's
going to go on to flank so when this
state is kind of completely filled which
is that we have the amount of chunks for
the video that we think that we have
we're complete and we can do all of the
downstream things that we actually need
to do now the nice thing about this is
that you may say to yourself oh Jordan
there's tons of room for partial
failures here and you are correct about
that right you know this step could fail
this step could fail and as a result you
know we might end up replaying one of
these events we might end up replaying
one of these events all of these events
are item potent which basically means
that even if we were to do it again it
would actually have the same effect as
if we had only done it one time so again
if I'm never able to actually DQ this
event from Rabbid mq if that fails what
would happen is it just gets reprocessed
it gets sent right back to S3 we then go
back to the kofka que saying hey we've
just completed this chunk again and then
even if that was already present on the
Flink node the Flink node would say
actually I already have the data for
this video and for this chunk I'm still
good to go you know I'm not double
processing this video I understand it's
a duplicate this is totally fine and so
through this all of these things are
item potent and our thing is completely
fault tolerant or at least I should
hope okay I did all that but it was a
bit abstract so let's go and actually
talk about the data models that we might
use putting into each of our cues which
should hopefully make this a little bit
more clear what we're actually doing so
we've got our client over here after
uploading to S3 the client is also going
to put some data in rabbit mq so the the
first idea is that again we've got kind
of our user ID because we're sharting by
user ID and video ID and so basically
let's imagine user 10 is uploading video
100 this is going to be the first chunk
here's the S3 link that we got after
uploading it we can put that in rabbit
mq the processor is going to process it
and from S3 it's going to say hey get me
s3.com
sl10 100 ABC S3 is going to respond to
it and then from there it's going to
basically put in Flink hey here's chunk
number one of video 10 or video 100 for
user 10 and then it's going to actually
provide a list of all the different
chunk copies that it made their
encodings their resolutions their hashes
their new S3 URL it can actually put
that in Flank In addition to that we've
got this second data model right here
which is more about the video meta data
right so for user 10 for video 100 there
are three total chunks the name is going
to be Jordan's feet and the description
is that they're so stinky wait that says
dainty fraudi and slip perhaps so
anyways we're going to put these in
Kafka and then they're eventually going
to flow over to Flink it doesn't
actually matter whether this message
gets the Flink before this message does
because at the end of the day both of
them are going to be required for us to
consider that video completed we're
going to store this data regardless on
Flink and we're going to store this data
regardless on Flink and then we're
effectively going to do a join on them
via the user ID and the video ID fields
and use this num chunks field right here
to determine when we're
done so hopefully that clears things up
a little bit but we've still got plenty
more to do as far as video uploading
goes we can actually tell when a video
has finished aggregating or when all
those chunks have been processed as
necessary but now we have to go to all
of our databases and actually say hey
here's the data that you were looking
for so again we can now begin to update
our derived data oops had the Eraser on
so we're updating our derived data and
at least to start we're going to put it
in two places the first is the video
chunks table right we've got now this
massive data model and we want to upload
it all at once automically into a single
partition we can do so by just
partitioning by the user ID and the
video ID so we make sure that for a
given video all of the chunk metadata is
on the same table after those video
chunks are uploaded we can then
basically go ahead and say hey let's now
upload to user videos so now we'll say
oh user 10 has video
100 and the name is Jordan's
feet now if you notice there is
technically a partial scenar a failure
scenario here where this guy goes
through number one when we upload to the
chunks table and number two goes and
fails that being said because this is
Flink we know that we're not actually
going to consider this event completely
acknowledged until number two goes
through so even if number one does go
through and two fails there's going to
be a small period of time where this
table is not as up to date as this table
but you can only really find that a
video exists if it's in the user videos
table so you're going to have a bunch of
Chunk metadata existing in this table
but no one's actually going to be able
to watch the video because they would
have to access it through the user
videos table and like going to a user's
page and clicking the video and so as a
result of that we basically wait for a
little bit this guy eventually comes
back up or someone else takes over the
state it retries the event until this
guy goes through and this guy goes
through and then we're good to go of
course this is totally fine as long as
all of those rights are item potent
because those chunks or the data for
those chunks is going to be the same
data you know from both before and after
this Flink node crashes it's just going
to override itself no big deal same
thing for the user videos table so again
no big deal so this is why the order is
important right if I had the user videos
table first first it might look like I
have actually posted a new video but
then when you click it you can't load
any chunks for it so again that's why
I've deliberately chosen to upload the
video chunks before the user video
metadata okay lots of video uploading
details for this one we've got plenty
more to go so basically the next part of
this is that some of our videos we
actually know in advance that they'll be
popular so this is pretty cool because
for a lot of social networks or social
medias you know it's very hard to say in
advance whether a post is going to be
popular if I'm blind and every single
person that's posting is an anonymous
user when a new post comes in I have no
idea whether people are actually going
to view it a lot or I don't that being
said with a service like YouTube or with
a service like Netflix we actually have
the privilege of knowing when a
particular video is going to be popular
in advance precisely because we know how
many subscribers they have right so
let's take my channel for example with
my 1 billion
subscribers and we can basically say hey
if Jordan's posting let's go ahead and
push this thing to a CDN so that way
when users originally try and load it
those chunks are going to load more
quickly we can go ahead and actually do
just that but how would we do it well in
the past you might have thought okay
well this guy is just going to be
partitioned by video ID right we're
sending video metadata we're sending
video chunks and at least intuitively it
would make a lot of sense if we
partitioned both the Kafka qes by video
ID and also if we partitioned uh Flink
by video ID
however what I'm now proposing is that
rather than do that we should be
partitioning everything by user
ID the reason being that the
subscriptions table can be partitioned
by the user ID so basically for my
user I know exactly who is subscribed to
me and as a result of that now I know
you know
Jordan has 10
subscribers and here his new videos he's
got this guy right here with video one
it's got three of three chunks he's got
this amount of subscribers Oh shoot
that's actually going to be a very
popular video so not only are we now
uploading to the video chunks table then
the user videos table but lastly we can
even upload to the CDN I think again
precisely the ordering is important here
because if these two succeed and then
the CDN fails now all of a sudden you
can still watch this video it's just
going to be a little bit slower we can
always do a poll based approach into the
CDN rather than a push based approach
but eventually it will get pushed to the
CDN because of how flank works so again
you know if we were to publish to the
CDN for example uh first then all of a
sudden we're taking up a bunch of room
in our CDN and the video is not even
watchable or you know just it would be a
bad situation so be careful when you're
doing these kind of sequential uploads
to actually think a little bit about
what the ordering
means okay let's now talk about actually
building a search index so this is is
also going to be a little bit
complicated I think I would rather do
this a bit more in depth in a separate
video so I'm not going to go too crazy
with this one but hopefully this should
outline some of the problems that you
have to consider when building a large
massively distributed search index so
for starters we want to take our video
title and we want to take our video
description and make sure that if anyone
searches for that video title or for
that video
description that they are easily
accessible and that that query is going
to be quick so the way that we do this
if you've watched my concept series is
via an inverted index so for example if
we've got video 22 over here and this is
the title of it we would want to split
out the main tokens like these guys
right
here and then we would go ahead and
basically say hey for this given word
here's a list of video IDs that actually
contain that word now of course as you
can see I only kind of took like the
four non-common words right here but how
you actually break this document up is
going to depend on the tokenization
process of the search index that you
actually use
okay so the next thing that we need to
think about is partitioning because
partitioning and the actual speed of our
query is directly dependent on you know
just how well we balance out our data if
we can keep all queries going to one
single node as opposed to having to
aggregate them over multiple different
nodes that is going to be a lot faster
so again ideally for a given search term
we would want the user ID and video ID
combo on a single node the question is
is it possible we've actually discussed
how much storage we have available we've
discussed how many videos we've posted
can we get this done let's say if we
post a million videos a day over 10
years that's about 4 billion videos so
if the user ID and the video ID are
integers that means combined they are 8
bytes in
total so 8 bytes * 4 billion is 32 GB of
IDs for a search term in theory that is
actually super possible however in
reality keep in mind that if we only
just s uh store the user ID and the
video IDs we can get those back but then
we would still have to do a distributed
query on our video metadata table in
order to actually get all of that data
back when we actually make the search
right because even though we have this
data we still have to get the names and
the descriptions and possibly the
thumbnails of those videos and so in
reality it's probably going to be a lot
more than 32 GB of IDs for a single term
and as a result of that we're probably
going to have to do more partitioning in
this so we've got basically a couple of
decently solid options the first being
that you know we don't do any term
specific partitioning and rather we just
you know kind of Round Rob in all the
documents and then keep a local index
per partition uh that can be okay but if
we have too many partitions let's say we
have 100 different partitions of search
indexes then now we have to aggregate a
100 different partitions of indexes
which is you know probably going to be
pretty expensive another perhaps hybrid
option is that you know where we can
store all the terms on one single node
that we
do that being said for very popular
terms you know take fortnite for example
we can actually do an inner Shard on
that and keep you know all the fortnite
documents on a combination of five nodes
and then you know have to aggregate
those together so let's do some search
index partitioning
continued so the idea is that in reality
we're going to have to store you know a
bunch of metadata for the video we're
going to have to denormalize our data a
little bit or else we're looking at
potentially a super expensive query so
we would denormalize our data by
basically continuing to store the video
name and the video description within
our search index and that of course is
going to take up more space meaning that
we can't partition in the way that we
necessarily completely wanted to so
rather than taking a super popular term
and trying to fit it all on one note
what we can do is actually repartition
that over a few different nodes and then
make some client side optimizations that
know to actually check all of those
nodes and aggregate them together so
internally you know ideally something
like elastic search would do this for us
but the idea would be you know you would
take a term like Jordan and then in
reality we would Shard that Via Jordan
dollar sign one Jordan dollar sign 2
Jordan dollar sign 3 and that way we can
kind of repartition our popular terms so
again what this also is going to mean is
that if we do keep our data denormalized
right if we store the actual title and
the description of the video within our
search index now all of a sudden if we
want to be able to edit those that's
going to get super expensive right
because now we have to actually find
where they are in the search index and
go ahead and change them the question is
do we actually care probably not really
because at the end of the day the
benefit of denormalizing our data within
the search index for reads and for
viewing videos is a lot bigger than kind
of the cost of having to have slow
uploads or slow edit speeds for our
video descriptions and titles so what
would that actually look like when we
bring it together well let's imagine we
have our user videos table which to
remind you is like a user
ID a video
ID uh a name a timestamp probably first
timestamp then name then
description blah blah blah blah blah we
can actually upload first to this table
then use change data capture to go ahead
and derive another table off of it where
we first sh by our video ID and as a
result of sharding by our video ID we
can ensure that the flank instance that
reads this data is actually going to
have the old video name and old video
description on it and so if we know the
old name and old description then we can
actually go to elastic search and
specifically tell it to remove that
video name and description elastic
search would then reach out to the
proper partitions remove them and then
also write the new ones now of course
this is going to be pretty expensive
right we might even find our ourselves
writing to 10 different partitions at a
time that being said a it's doable B we
don't really care because even if it
takes a couple minutes for that video
name change to propagate to other users
it doesn't really matter as long as
they'll eventually see it so this does
seem like a feasible solution personally
of course as always if you guys in the
comment section have a better idea I'm
open to hearing
it and then of course finally we've got
this absolute Behemoth of a diagram so
let's go ahead and talk about it the
first thing that I'm going to start with
is going to be the top left so if we're
looking over here we've got our load
balancer which goes to our horizontally
scaled user service the user service is
going to be responsible for both the
user table as well as the subscriber
table so the user table is going to be
sharded on the user ID because this is
not something that's probably going to
be a bottleneck I think just using my
SQL and partitioning that and
replicating it in a single leader
fashion is going to be fine additionally
we've got our subs table right that can
be fine with my SQL we don't really
subscribe to channels that often right
you know maybe once a day or something
and so WR speeds are probably not going
to be the bottleneck there more
importantly I just care about
correctness so as long as we Shard this
guy on user ID right not who they're
subscribed to but who is actually doing
the subscribing we can use change data
capture to eventually put this into our
flank node over here so it is eventually
going to fall over there additionally
we've got our comment service right for
a given video
we have the ability to comment on it and
as a result of the fact that certain
videos may have a lot of comments I
think that using the increased right
through putut that Cassandra gives us
could be very good all we have to do is
Shard by the channel ID and the video ID
and then sort on the time stamp of the
comment and we should be good to go keep
in mind that Cassandra will actually
present problems if we start to try and
edit comments or start to have child
comments uh but I would consider that
more of a stretch goal uh worse comes to
worse we could always use single leiter
replication and then just add more
partitions I think that would be pretty
feasible as well though it may be a
little bit more
expensive finally the most important
piece of the puzzle is going to be the
upload service so the first thing that
we do when we're uploading is we're
going to upload all of our chunks to S3
from there we're going to do two things
our upload service is going to put the
actual video metadata such as the number
of chunks the name and the description
in Kafka and it's actually going to put
references to the chunks in rabbit mq
rabbit mq is going to allow us to
efficiently load balance the processing
of these chunks to our chunk processing
nodes which are going to read them from
S3 all the way over here and then
ideally write them or rather write the
result of them right back into S3 and
again put the references of those into
Kafka before they actually DQ them from
rabbit
mq once those chunk processors actually
go ahead and do that we've now got all
of these chunk completed events in Kafka
and so the idea here is that the chunk
completed events are going to have
access to the user ID that's posting the
video the video ID of the video and as
long as we sh it on user ID then what we
can ensure is that Flink knows for a
given user num
subscribers it knows the video Numb
chunks and it knows the chunks that are
completed chunks
completed and so so once all of those
things are done it can perform all of
the external events that it needs to do
as long as these are item potent this
should be totally fine so of course the
first thing that we would want to do is
actually upload to the video chunks
table remember order is going to be
important here this is going to be
number one number two is going to be
uploading to the user videos table right
that is going to help us out quite a bit
because now it's going to say hey this
video is actually accessible once you
click it we're going to start reading
from the video chunks table and that'll
tell us what to read from S3 on the
client side number three is if this user
is a popular user if they have a lot of
subscribers we can read from the CDN and
then last but not least from our user
videos table we can do some sort of
change data capture which basically says
hey we know all of these users have
videos now we can see that one of them
was either uploaded or you know if I'm a
client and I'm writing over here to
actually change the name of my video
it's still going to flow through the
same exact pipeline we're then going to
go into this video metadata que which of
course is going to be Kafka so that we
can use Flink again we can go ahead and
Shard on the video ID itself so that we
have access to the old name and old
description of that video and then of
course we can make whatever removes or
adds to elastic search that we need to
make I have elastic search is one big
circle here right now I want to keep
this abstract because I'm going to go
into a lot more depth on it in a future
video but the gist is elastic search is
probably going to have to write to a
bunch of different partitions and that's
okay we don't really need this to be
fast we just need it to work the only
thing that we really need to be fast is
this guy right here reading from S3
reading from the video chunks table in
reality there would probably be some
sort of caching layer on the video
chunks table particularly for popular
videos but uh I've chosen not to go into
that too much because we've already seen
how caching is going to work in
distributed
setting anyways guys wow this was a long
one so far the longest by far and uh
yeah great stuff thanks for hanging in
there uh my voice hurts so I'm going to
go drink some water uh my throat hurts
geez I can't even speak I'm losing it
and I am now going to go to sleep so
with that being said have yourselves a
great week I hope you enjoyed this one
and I will see you in the next one